i got more good news for you what's up
so people often talk about the secret
trump voter or the shy trump voter
there's actually a research that was
done that came out at the end of august
that asked the question how do you
figure out if people are actually
lying to the pollsters to figure out if
the numbers make sense
because you what are you supposed to do
you ask somebody like who you're voting
for and they say biden
are you lying to me no okay so how do
you know if they're actually lying
so they ask people questions like uh you
know do
you feel that you can be truthful about
you know who you would vote for and see
if i said yes or no would you be
worried at all if you know someone asked
you how you really felt yes or no
and what they ended up finding and it's
like seven phds that did this project
10.1 of the polled voters
are likely trump supporters who are
lying about their vote
you know what that means that's a 20
swing wow so well hold on
you've got biden nationally at 9.2 up in
the rcp aggregate
imagine if ten percent of the vote was
secretly for trump
then it would put trump at plus one
percent yeah guess what else no we put
him at plus
plus 11 because biden would be down 10
no and trump would go up 10.
right so so so biden's at 50 trump said
40 biden would go to 40 and trump would
go to 50.
get it so plus it isn't it it is a
20-point swing
so but here here's here's what's
interesting the sunday express poll that
trump tweeted out guess what it shows
trump plus one huh so i'm wondering if
when a british company says how you
voting they went no it's a british
company i'm voting for trump
when the americans call and they're like
i i'm an american journalist who are you
voting for
biden biden i swear are you being honest
yes please don't come to my house with
the antifa
i don't know if people are actually
freaking out in that capacity i'm kind
of kidding
they do no i was in new hampshire
and i knock on this woman's door in the
front and she's got a little side area
and she doesn't answer the door right
away we're about to leave and she comes
out to the side
and she's real shy and timid young thing
too i'd say like
early 30s and she goes is my neighbor
next door i said you know we we didn't
knock we didn't see anybody
and she goes i have a question for you
she goes
did you know that if you type in
antifa.com it goes to jail by this
i swear i swear to god if someone just
didn't swear to god
i know but still the fact is this woman
was so
shy and timid about even asking that
question
and whether or not her neighbor would
overhear this conversation
and i just said back to her you know the
reason why i'm supporting president
donald trump is because i want law and
order
and i want to make sure that we're
upholding our laws and defending our
police you know i really went in on the
law
order since that clearly was important
to her but it just shows me those shy
voters
exist and she's the suburban woman that
doesn't want antifa or blm
burning down her city they're out there
they found that 11
of republicans were were worried about
sharing their true opinions
about sure it's more than that i think
it was 10 10.5 percent of independents
were scared and 5.4
of democrats were scared all in all with
the entire voter base
they said it was around 10.1 percent
were uh uh 10.1 percent
of the shy vote were trump supporters or
i want
i'm probably i got to be very careful
with language because i think it was
something like
10 of the trump supporters were saying
they weren't voting for trump that's
basically okay
so i i i don't know if this like look
man
the polls right now have biden like
ridiculously up
it's just it's just insane and and i got
to be real
if donald trump wins with polling where
it's at right now like if it stays where
it is
it will be probably the one of the most
insane historical american presidency
upsets ever
it won't stay the same for sure i think
as we close our deduction things will
change
but i feel like the media is going to
come out and be like we did a new
weighted poll and joe biden's up 73
donald trump's at one percent approval
and the rest is all george jorgensen
people are gonna like i'm exaggerating
obviously joe's gonna win
utah do you think you know like they did
with no oh gary johnson no
like they did with um evan mcmullen
remember when they said that he was
gonna win utah
and they had that pipe dream
the wait for those those theories are
gonna come out that's gonna be great
crowder was asking are polls
actually just propaganda i think it's
great yes or are they actually
referencing what is coming i think they
are propaganda yeah well
it's a fact several studies have been
done
there's a large faction of people who
will vote for who they think is going to
win
so when the polls keep coming out saying
it's biden what they're trying to do
is just convince i think i think the
polls for the most part there's no
conspiracy
but there are weighted polls where
they're very clearly favoring democrats
that sounds like a conspiracy i think of
a media company as doing a weighted po
like
look there there's democrat pollsters
there's that's not trying to make it
look like a democrat's winnings
but they do that all the time they're
conspiring to get people to vote
democrat
conspiracy 101. so i i think what ends
up happening is
if joe biden is if the media keeps
saying over and over again he's winning
he's winning he's winning
then they're trying to demoralize trump
supporters which i don't think will work
because pete has the opposite effect
right people like i i think well i think
trump supporters don't care about the
polls for the most part
i think voting for donald trump is an f
u to the establishment so it's like that
you have that one opportunity to tell
joe biden and the obama administration
to shove it
and it's hitting that you know that
donald trump button
that's what people want i feel like and
the media too like because i
really am sick okay man i've been
ranting on this nonstop
brian stelter of cnn is is claiming now
on mainstream cable television that
there is a government conspiracy
between the military pilots the secret
service
all of the doctors at walter reed donald
trump his staff to cover up
that he's actually really sick even
though the president walked out of the
hospital of his own volition and then
waved everybody
then what happens the guardian puts out
a video and they're like donald trump is
gasping for air
and it's trump just going like
like he just he oh he's like standing
there and he like opens his mouth takes
a breath he's like
and then he waves and they're like oh
he's gasping wait aren't these the same
people that criticize them for having
two scoops of ice cream
yeah well that was supposed to be
tongue-in-cheek but the problem is many
of
them
ended up taking it seriously seriously
so there yeah so it was funny because
there's there's a woman at cnn who does
kind of jokey segments
and she was like donald trump gets two
scoops of ice cream well
everyone gets one it's supposed to be
silly
but then you ended up with like i think
don lemon did a segment about it he's
like did you see this two scoops of ice
cream oh god
do you see the salt shaker one no where
there were like trump's salt and pepper
shakers are bigger than everyone else's
oh my gosh i can't believe that stuff
dude
the the cnn challenge is to turn on like
turn on fox news during a major
international news story
and then flipped to cnn so i did this
several times
it's like i turn on fox news and it's
like riot's erupting in iran the
you know the the government says this
says and i'm like huh cnn well but
donald trump was saying and i'm like
okay
then like a week later i turn on fox
news and they're like storms are coming
this season we can expect major flooding
i'm like it's the weather
but the weather's important people turn
on cnn well what donald trump said
that's the cnn challenge you turn on you
turn on cnn it is just
donald trump but but anyway here's my
point
unhinged conspiracies about a government
cover-up
if there was a cover-up of donald
trump's health that would mean the
doctors are in on it
the ap photographer who took pictures of
trump was in on it the pilots of the
helicopter was in on it the secret
service they're all in on it
there's no conspiracy trump was just not
really that sick he went to the hospital
because he's the president and they were
like well he's got some mild symptoms he
should go to the hospital
and now they're pumping that out with
impunity social media doesn't care they
let him do it
so that that that that donald trump
button isn't just about trump
it's about the entire establishment the
democrats and the media
oh yeah i mean like when you vote for
donald trump i take extreme pleasure in
knowing that i'm voting against joy
behar
alyssa milano and jim acosta like all at
once
like that i already voted early and in
person so my vote is locked in
oh yeah i voted with mom and dad oh heck
can you say where you're from do
people know where you're oh yeah i live
in fairfax virginia i voted in northern
virginia
right on you so there you can i don't
know you could do that you can go vote
in person
early and in person you guys should do
that voted at the fairfax government
center
yeah you virginia no no
back in jersey okay because oh well
joycey
governor up there he's doing some
mischief you guys only get to vote by
mail by the way however
to everybody in jersey that's watching
don't
send it through the usps you can drop
off your ballot
in person at the drop off box
and then that way you're still kind of
voting in person one of the big problems
though is that
you got to know all the rules for how
the mail and bouts work oh it's so tough
and people have never done it before no
so like i was watching
uh i was actually watching john oliver
which is the was the weirdest thing
right no no when you when you walked in
i was watching the gravel institute you
see
i watch what the left is talking about i
watch the view sometimes
well i feel sorry for that you you're
enduring very
serious trials and tribulations for the
american people i respect that
anyway um what was i talking i was
watching john oliver
and he actually he talks about how some
of the ballots
have a secret envelope you put it in and
then put these secret envelope in
another envelope
and most people have no i like what
doesn't make sense
so interestingly about the john oliver
thing
is that he's ragging on trump but then
talking about how maryland voting was
broken
he was like 500 000 bouts rejected
and this is why it's so important and
i'm like yo that was the democrats
the republicans said don't do it it's
broken so who are you mad at
he's like the lost stepchild not there's
anything wrong with being a stepchild of
jon stewart so there's some semblance of
legitimacy to him
they took jon stewart and then they made
it jon stewart mold
of this like here's jon stewart's
formula and it's not
you know what really offended me about
john the john oliver segment is that he
was like
in 1980 people actually started showing
up to polls with revolvers and armbands
to
to guard you know the republicans sent
them out and he's like which is
basically what the nazis were doing with
revolvers and armbands and threatening
the poles
and then it shows like germany like with
arrows pointing to poland and i was like
bro they never revolvers they had lugers
come on get your guns right i'm not even
a gun person i know that germans had you
know
like they weren't using revolvers back
then it's an impressive weapon
but the jokes fell flat to say the least
but you know i guess long story short
with that segment is i saw this lefty
dude who posted it
and i was like i don't understand who
you're mad at like you watch this
segment and he's basically saying mail
in voting is completely
like broken bro that's your fault you
keep you keep screaming that donald
trump is claiming the election is going
to be
you know fraudulent or you know improper
or inaccurate
he was right now john oliver's
complaining about it okay fine let's
play the game
trump said without evidence and john
oliver said
also without evidence apparently that
mail-in voting is gonna have problems
because if if you're telling me that
trump said it without evidence then why
are we giving a free pass to john oliver
how about this whenever donald trump
says it put a little asterisks and then
and then show the clip of john oliver
saying exactly it
just just tweet that out like here's
trump and then right underneath it is
john oliver like ranting and showing you
the same thing
maybe then people get it you will
understand it's all broken
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you